[موسيقى]
سهام رحمون حاصل على الاجازه في القانون
الخاص
هل يمكن تشتغل على تربيه الابقار الحلو
[موسيقى]
حيوان في 700 ولا 800 كيلو
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
من القانون الفلاحه يعني
مني خديت الاجازه ديالتي تقدمت بعد
المباريات وما نجحت مني ما توظفتش
قررت انني نشتغل في الارض
[موسيقى]
وانا مفكر انني بحكم انني بنت العروبيه
وعندنا الارض فكرت ندير واحد المشروع
فلاحي اللي هو تربيه ديال الابقار
[موسيقى]
كنبدا اليوم ديالي مع الصباح بكري كنبداو
نحلبوا ما كنحلبوش بالطريقه التقليديه
كنحلبوه بطريقه العصريه
[موسيقى]
الحلبه كندوزو للماكله
كنوزعو الماكله على بقره وعلى العجلات
الصغار كل واحد على حساب الكميه شحال
[موسيقى]
كياكلوا فيا
حيوان فيه 700 ولا 800 كيلو كتعامل معه
[موسيقى]
ديال الحليب ولا هاد البقر اللي كنستوردو
حنايا من اجل الحليب راه غالي غالي بزاف
يعني القدره كيوصل حتى ثلاثه مليون لبكره
الواحده
فاش بغيت نمول المشروع ديالي المسؤولين
ديال المؤسسه ديالنا ربما كتجي امراه ما
غاديش تقدر ولا ماقتانوش والفكره ديال
تربيه الابقار الحلو خصوصا ملي كتكون انت
بنت وجاي من الجامعه مشيت البنوك مشيت كان
واحد البرنامج يلاه انطلاق ديالو يعني
الدوله دخلات باش تغطي هاد المساله هادي
خديت القرض وبديت في المشروع ديالي
وبنيت واحد الكوري اللي المساحه ديالتهم
مزيانه ديال العشره ديال البقر يعني واخا
الامكانيات بسيطه يكونوا فيه شروط العصريه
[موسيقى]
البدايه كانت صعيبه اشتريت عشره البقرات
غاليين بزاف وما تولين ثلاثه
يعني بدايه المشوار لك ثلاثه راه صعيب
ولكن خلاو ليا واحد الدرس وتعلمت فيهم
وتعلمنا حتى الصبر يعني راه رباح راه
مكيجيش بسهوله
[موسيقى]
الجفاف يقدر يهرس المشروع خصوصا في
البدايه باش نواجه الجفاف حاولت نتج واحد
واحد كميه لا باس بها فيهم الاعلاف ديالي
وليت كنتج الفصه وكننتج الوصيلاج وليت
كنوفر واحد الجزء واحد النسبه من الارض
ديالتي
البقرات كيعطوني يعني المعدل العام تقريبا
22 يترو في النهار
[موسيقى]
جزء من الحياه ديالي يعني ولاو كنقولو
بالدارجه فاش كتدخل لك شي حاجه للدم كتولي
من العائله
[موسيقى]
وانت
وبس اللي حبيبي هاد العمل هذا
بالعكس يعني حنا كبرنا معه
العيالات ومع موادنا كيخدموا في المجال
الفلاحي وكيخليه المراه دائما امراه يعني
واش غادي تبدل شي كئيب اخر
هاد المشروع هذا في المستقبل غادي يكون
ناجح وغادي يكون نموذج ديال المراه
القرويه اللي قاريه وناجحه
[موسيقى]